I
ok so here with Victoria knee and
Victoria this is your first u.s. women's
chess championship what are you looking
forward to the most oh you know I don't
I do play like I like my goal is to get
some maybe grandmasters norm woman been
mastered my goal and I'm stud I was time
to study but not so much you know with
the baby sweetie see ya I speaking of
your baby you've had your baby during
last year's US Championship when your
husband your children was competing yeah
he must have been conflicted with his
first child at home how did that get a
range no like for me it was not a
problem you know like like chess players
club I think very strong like humans you
know
they're absolutely normal is it and like
for me and it's okay you know there was
some friends and there was your
experience so yeah well you such as
players are very strong humans i notice
you played in the chicago open only
maybe three or four weeks after having
your first child yes were you able to
focus on the game yes but they you know
i miss just so much so like I I decided
to play in on my mom and came this
is my baby and yeah it was not so easy i
can tell you so it's kind of like you
gave birth and you had a rebirth and
chest yes for you did was absolutely
opposite you know he lost 50 like you
know I hope after right now is Gabriel
is one year old some may still go back I
hope your mom taught you and I assume
that very soon will pass on your
knowledge to Gabriel he turned one how
many years you're gonna wait until you
introduce chest to him maybe still until
three bro essen until three it's not so
you know right well have to be pretty
smart to learn at three but he comes
from good genetics hopefully you know
you can like we can develop some
mathematical abilities we can try to
develop a person but you know chess it's
like something you don't want to push is
it you know sometimes when you push it's
like too much and
just don't have such a difficult well
thanks Victoria for your time thank you
so much look at the u.s. women's chess
championship thank you so much